I remember uh I told the story before
about when I was at the Dakota access
pipeline protest and I had a white dude
tell me that uh Asian when he mentioned
that being on time for meetings was
colonial thinking nope nice what he told
me and then I was like what are you
talking about I was like I have a
meeting I gotta leave and he's like
that's what the colonists Native
Americans didn't do that they just you
know they knew when to wake up and then
I was like what are you talking about
Asians have us have have schedules too
like what what and he was like yeah but
let's be real like white people brought
that stuff to Asia and I was like Asians
invented the compass 1000 years before
you did dude I'm not gonna sit here
listen to a white supremacist tell me he
invented all culture in the world but
these people genuinely believe it they
like they're white people who think they
did everything and anything good and
like stoic or work related or
responsible is they think it's just them
and they must bring it to all the lowly
others